born on May 7 1996 and raised in Seoul
South Korea
Faker was raised by a single
parent his father who believed that
Faker was born to be a pro gamer as a
as a child Faker played the Moba Chaos but moved on
to League of Legends in December 2011
when he found the game while browsing
the web it didn't take long for him to
become sought after by several Korean
teams however having just entered high
school at the time the decision to turn
pro was a tough one in the end a Faker
would drop out and join SK Telecom's T1
secondary squad a team which was
specifically built around his prodigious
talents the team immediately performed
topping their group during the og and
Olympus Champions Spring in 2013
SK Telecom will win a 52 minute game they
to get the duo and come out of the group
stages at champions winter with a
perfect score
and eventually finishing third in the playoffs
Faker quickly made a name for himself
his solo kills against Ambition and a
dominant game on Leblanc against MVP
Blue gained him significant attention is
wow wow Ambition what Faker just
execute Ambition in that mid lane
but it wasn't until 2013
Summer Finals where Faker were truly shocked the world
you have just make are nightmares you wake up in a cold sweat
your like Faker behind me
I know right
(Casting)
SK Telecom T1 K won
their first Og title that day earning
them a spot in the 2013 World
Championship and giving Faker a chance
to prove who the medal internationally
SK Telecom T1 K carved a trail through
the event sweeping Royal Club 3-0 in the
grand finals to claim their first Worlds tittle
potentially gonna go down this could be a 20 minute game for SK Telecome
they will be the season 3 World
Champion
here at the Staples Center
as if it were possible his dominant
performance on the world stage even
further increased the buzz around Faker
and he was looked to as the best in the world
most impressive victory at the end SKT is
the team
Faker and his team returned home
on top of the league of legends world
and continued his nearly unhindered success
(Casting)
the path seemed set to another world
appearance however Faker and his team
which faced their first stumbling block
with back-to-back disappointments in the
spring and summer season of 2014
(Casting)
with one last shot at worlds through the
regional qualifiers SKT T1 K came up
short to NaJin White Shield 3-1
(Casting)
the disappointing finish to the year
called for a change Impact and Piglet
left the team and due to the removal of
sister teams in OGN leaves SK Telecom's
two squads were merged into one bringing
in the fresh talent of MaRin Easyhoon
Bang and Wolf into the picture
for the
first time Faker had competition for his
starting role and he and Easyhoon would
split the duties throughout the season
(Casting)
despite the changes to their roster SKT
went 11 and 3 and were able to punch it
to get to MSI
there they swept through
the group stage however during the
finals against EDward Gaming
SKT decided to start Easyhoon against Pawn
a player against whom Fake had famously struggle
right now imported to know that Easyhoon will be starting in game 1
as sad as I am to not see Faker couple game 1
I think it's the preferable choices
yes
Easyhoon played the first three
games and SKT went down 1-2
whatever they want at this point
SKT forced to surrender there was
no way they're coming back their
back against the wall Faker would swap back in for the fourth game with the set
two-on-one
(casting)
for SKT Calvary here Goro is trying to
take everything he goes down to bang now
4:02
SKT very low and this is going to be the
pawn cleanup ships over the wall that
stops it goes over the wall these deaf
(Casting)
SKT won forcing a deciding game 5
during the draft EDG
decided to leave LeBlanc open
a champion on whom Faker had never lost a competitive game
(Casting)
it was a decision that
would go down in history
as the decision proved to be a bait
so Morgana is
actually a lane count for match up to
Leblanc
Faker would have to find other ways of
winning this game whether it's to
banking or to roaming
(Casting)
while Faker tried his best playing well despite the counterpick
EBG would win the game and
the MSI title
handing Faker this first ever lost
on Leblanc
the lost left Faker distraught
(Casting)
after their loss at MSI SKT bounce back
Faker was returning to his dominant form
and now had the opportunity to win his
second world championship
(Casting)
no matter this teammate
no matter the opposition that rose
against him Taker and SKT proved to be
all but unstoppable
so with two world championships under this belt
Faker set this sights on the
only international tournament he had yet
to win MSI
welcome ladies and gentlemen
to the League of Legends midseason
Invitational Finals
after the disappointment of MSI 2015
this was Fakers chance to redeem him self
(Casting)
the MSI coupled with SKT's triumph at
IEM Katowice earlier in the year
meant that SKT and Faker could complete the
international grand slam with a victory
that worlds
and that right there makes it
all worth it
but nothing worthwhile
comes without a fight
welcome to the 2016 League of Legends
World Championship final live from
LosAngeles California
I'm games I think this is going to be
one for the record books SKT
best of all time
(Casting)
despite a very close match SKT came out
victorious
solidifying back-to-back
World Championship wins to go along with
completing the international grand slam
we have to highlight our world's MVP who
did some serious serious work over the
last month competition to bring SK
Telecom T1 to their third championship
and no surprise it's the man himself
Faker
and you doubted him
you talk you know this is a guy
honestly he's had such an impressive
world run this guy is a he deserves it
he's the best plan to ever pick up a mouse and keyboard in League of Legends
this also
marks Faker's third world championship
making him and his teammate Bengi the
only two players in League of Legends
history to complete the feat
SKT and Faker returned home to Korea as world
champions once again
with an even bigger
target on their back but despite super
teams forming to challenge them and
significant roster changes along the way
Faker finds himself once again back at
MSI set to add another championship to
his already stocked cabinet of trophies